now I'll go easy on you for this because
it is the first example where do you see
what I mean by now extension one
students you can momentarily to doubt if
you like because Sager assists we'll
never get a question that just says that
okay just by itself that's the question
however this could appear like something
like this that's simpler could appear it
within an induction proof but it's not
gonna appear by itself now I'm gonna get
easier you unlock and expect like I've
given you a whole life by the way when I
learnt that those properties are listed
off for you I love them as a list of
like 15 separate things and I was like
what do any of these have to do with
each other so I've sought to try and
show you how they relate to each other
that's what the category is about I'm
not going to expect you to see this and
think ah I know exactly what category go
for it's actually got a bit of a red
herring in it which is also why I'm
going to do this example so what do you
think's the obvious red herring the
obvious red herring is a bother if you
don't know what it is it's a it's a
false clue is there as a reciprocal
there okay so I see reciprocal so they
all are they gonna be in reciprocals
involved there are not really yeah
they're a simple guy I'm not really
gonna be able to use the reciprocal
effectively because I need to reserve
room basically and you could take
reciprocals of both sides that ends up
just being an algebraic disaster so I'm
going to start with something else I'm
gonna say no and I'm going to use one of
the properties
I already know with a particular values
okay now you're thinking okay yeah all
right alternate second you're thinking
how did I do it too good there and the
answer is I didn't know immediately okay
but I've I've got some experience with
these they are what are the clues one of
the crews was this guy here right he's
sort of flirting there you like what is
that about right it's easy to personally
positive easy for something's negative
but where does he come from and the
answer is he comes to combining these in
a particular way right it has to be to
do with square e squaring comes out like
95% of the time with inequalities the
squaring tells you this way or you not
have a look at the left-hand side let's
expand this there okay what happens when
you square this hey what happens when
you do the lightest way baby it's just
going to be minus 200 that was it it
looks so a 2-day because you didn't have
the lenses to see oh what am I supposed
to use in this case right so he is just
a pretty trivial addition
sorry say it again slower
hey - what thing 100 minus one all
squared and then divided through yeah
the reason you can do that is because
this just gets me there faster okay now
remember I said to you before hey you
can also do a proof by contradiction
that's a proof by contradiction so let's
assume here's a second way to do it this
is proof with inequalities it's really
nice they set up nicely for proofs by
contradiction because actually one of
the trickiest things where the proof my
conclusion is of knowing what is the
exact opposite of what you're talking
about
okay so I'll give you an example if I
say to you are a number is positive
sorry a number is even you might think
are the opposite of that is another
being odd but it's not true because a
number can be neither even nor odd right
as severe is an obvious one but there's
kind of a lot of other numbers that not
how about all the numbers between the
numbers that are even and odd like all
those infinities of like just a 1 and a
half is one and a half even or odd the
answer is it's neither of them right so
you'd be careful visit you can actually
do this by the way but they're not
called proof by contradiction
they called proof by country positive
you can go look it up if you're really
curious however an inequality set up
perfectly for proof by contradiction
because you can very easily state the
exact opposite of this you can say
assume that in fact it's not greater
than or equal to to assume that it's
less than to assume that's less than 2
now if this is the case what would you
like me to do let's just stop
let's go with what you guys suggested to
me before I think I could do it
yeah I can do it okay so what you guys
are suggesting before is to take
advantage of this property which means I
can multiply through by this stuff up
cause it's positive and it preserves
each part so I'm going to say this
okay multiply everything through by a
yes okay so then I'm going to subtract
okay so what am I going to do with the
left hence I know what is that okay so
this is actually a takeaway was square
oh oh I've been a problem right I could
say but but but but a takeaway one
that's the thing being squared it's a
real mo because A's a real number so
subtracting what doesn't take it out of
the real field right it's still a real
number so if it's a real nut bar you
can't that can't be the face right so
therefore you have a contradiction
and just for long I always refer to
nature with an exclamation mark okay no
this clearly can't be the game
ridiculous
so therefore if your assumption assuming
all of your logic is sound right
therefore your assumption must have been
wrong
so therefore a plus one on a is not less
than two and the only way for it to be
not less than two is it for it to be
greater than and perfectly